Speaker 1: Let's go to the phones, which are
really just an Internet voice server via discord.
You can find it at David Pakman dot com slash
discord.
The waiting lobby is where you go to talk
to me.
Let's start with Harpur from South Carolina,
Harpur from South Carolina.
You are on the air right now.
Speaker 3: Hi, great to talk to you today.
Speaker 1: Likewise.
Speaker 3: So I was wondering with I don't
know, have you heard about Kovács?
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 3: So what are your thoughts on that,
and do you think that that's practical?
Speaker 1: Yeah, and what what what specifically
would not be practical?
Speaker 3: Well, I've been thinking about
it, and I was I was looking into it a little
bit and I saw that it doesn't really there's
still it wasn't requiring the.
The the richer, more developed countries to
not not have that priority that they have
with their deals when they gave one hundred
or one hundred thousand dollars or whatever,
Tufte or a billion dollars to Bizer to get
however many doses, they still have those
agreements.
So it's not actually getting people in less
developed countries the doses that they need.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you're not wrong.
But here's the thing.
Soon the wealthier countries are going to
have all the vaccines that there's demand
for.
It's going to happen relatively soon.
It'll feel kind of slow because we're going
through it day by day.
But in a relatively short period of time,
that's going to happen.
So the fact that they've committed the money,
I don't believe that the actual distribution
is happening any more slowly because of the
requirements that you're talking about were
in there.
I think you'd have less buy in.
So I think that it's a way to get financial
commitments.
The vaccines are not getting to poor countries
nearly quickly enough, but I don't think they'd
get there any more quickly if you had the
requirements you're talking about, because
a lot of the rich countries would just say,
yeah, it's not for us and we're not going
to put any money in.
Speaker 3: Do you think there's any way around
that because what's happening in India is
just disgusting and terrible?
Speaker 1: I don't think there is.
I mean, vaccines are starting to get to India.
It's not going to help people that are dying
every day right now.
It's not going to help now.
Yeah, no, I don't think there's any way around
it, unfortunately.
Speaker 3: Darn, I was really hoping that
you had some miracle solution.
Speaker 1: No, no, by no means what's happened.
There's no miracle solution coming to India
other than the numbers are slowing down.
At least the growth rates are slowing down.
Speaker 3: OK, that's good.
Yeah, good.
I haven't heard updates since then.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: All right, thanks, Harpur, appreciate
the call.
Thank you.
All right, very good.